[Music]
on today's show we talked to an
incredible wife
and mother who is struggling with
resentment in her marriage
she doesn't know what to do we also
talked to a brand new father
who has a new little baby and he doesn't
really like him
stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up it's john with the dr john
delony show
so glad that you're joining us man this
is a show that
will lift you up just like kelly was
lifting me up
right before we went live this is a
direct quote
man john you'd be good looking if it
wasn't for your body
and your face
[Music]
i thought we were all about honesty on
this show no i'm going to take what you
said and twist it and make it sound
like that's what you meant
you're a treasure you're looking at
present for your skin and your teeth
and your face and your upper body thanks
kelly
love you and also with you hey man you
got to put that brick down
don't throw it at me just put it down i
am actually going to call my own show
here in a few weeks and because i need
to talk to myself
because i live in a hostile working but
i don't i live with i work with great
people
and so hey we're so glad that you joined
us we talked about
literally everything on the show
including my physical defects of which i
didn't know how many i had
until i started working here talking
about your mental health relationships
everything right so
give me a call at 1-844-6
that's 1-844-693-3291
leave a message and let me know what you
want to talk about and we will get you
on the show
or you can go to our new web address at
johndaloni.com
ask ask johndaloney.com ask
fill out the form and it will go right
to kelly she'll probably hit delete but
she might
not hey so cool cool news
um we got an email from
brian from norfolk uk
across the pond hello everyone
is that right brynn bro oh
i just thought they didn't use
consonants over there i mean i thought
they didn't use vowels no that's
millennials
so mr brenn from norfolk
uk here's what he says is that right
hello dr d that's not right that doesn't
sound good please stop
just read it hi dr d on your most recent
episode
to go out on your youtube channel you
didn't end with a song because the show
had been particularly heavy
it made sense but i came away feeling
particularly heavy myself and i'm not
sure why
thinking it through i realized you left
the closure loop open
dude you should go to grad school man
genius
i'm a long time listener and i'm used to
the harrowing stories that get on your
show
but when you end with song lyrics it's
like a little indicator to compose
myself and remind myself these aren't my
emotions and pains i'm feeling
there's somebody else's it's almost
pavlovian oh my gosh
you are in grad school so when the
episode finished without the lyrics it
was likely my brain never got the
message to release this stuff that
didn't belong to me
you're allowed to finish your show
however you want but it's just an
interesting moment
of self-reflection dude you are right
brynn from norfolk uk
you're right so here's my commitment i
will do some sort of song at the end of
every show
just to close the loop and let us all
say we can all put that down and then go
on about our days
new and with more information i like
that man that's awesome
so thanks for sending this in if you
have something you want to send in i
love it man i love the emails
send them to me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com johndaloney.com
ask all right let's go to the phones
let's go to
andy in salt lake city utah
hey andy what's up hi dr john how are
you
i'm good hey is there a song i don't
think there's a song about salt lake
city i'm gonna look it up on the
internets after the show
you don't even have to answer that so
hey what's going on how can i help
so i wanted to call today to ask you to
elaborate on something that
you say on your show a lot and as well
as on dave's show
which is uh resentments like the death
of a relationship
and i was hoping you'd go a little bit
deeper
on that what happens if marriage is
inching closer and closer to that
um and just how to deal with that how to
extend grace
i love that question um i do say that a
lot i don't ever explain it so i
appreciate you asking that
this sounds um uniquely personal to you
so tell me what's going on in your life
um it is very personal i've been married
for 11 years
um my husband is wonderful i think he
um carries a lot of i don't know if it's
a factor of his adhd or ptsd but
he changes a lot and i feel like it's a
part of
him not being content with himself so
whether it's big personality changes or
big purchases
or just big life moves because he's not
content
and it's tiring sometimes
it's tiring a lot of the time um more i
more need structure and need stability
and i don't feel like i'm getting that
and i feel like
i just i have a hard time extending
grace when i see him
basically flailing and it's really hard
on it's been hard on our marriage
thanks for sharing that that's hard um
have you ever sat down and said
i need some more stability well i have
how did that go yeah
um it really
it really gets through because i think
he sees it too
but that's to the extent that he gets to
and then
he comes up with another idea of how
we could get through that part where
because i i really open up when i'm just
really struggling
um we moved away from
you know a lot of support system that i
had even though his work is so
demanding and so he's not home a lot and
so i'm really struggling right now and
so i reach out to him and i say this is
i need more support i need more
stability
and so he'll come up with some new idea
or new way
or he'll want to give up a lot of
different things and
that's the extent of it and i find
myself really struggling to trust
new ideas new endeavors new
every everything even though he seems so
excited about things because
as soon as he gets there he finds
himself miserable again and so anymore i
feel like i give a lot of pushback
on those things well in in many ways
you sound like you are
frustrated with yourself and so if
somebody's telling you they're going to
do something
and they don't do it or they telling
they tell you hey i've got a solution to
this
i i realize you feel untethered i
realize i moved you halfway across the
country to go do something
and so i'm gonna do these three things
that are gonna help
and they don't do those things or they
do them for a minute and then they
change
that's called lying it's dishonest it's
not truthful
and so i don't want you to beat yourself
up for being frustrated
okay i don't want you to beat yourself
up for feeling lonely
or feeling exhausted those are all real
real real
okay the challenge is when you slip over
into
resentment right all resentment is is
when you believe that you're being left
out that you're not being treated fairly
you're not being treated in a way that
you believe you deserve
that's what resentment is right that you
are left out of the party nobody's
holding
um nobody's having fireworks shows in
your honor
that's what resentment is and then
when you start believing that this is
about me
i'm being left out treated poorly i'm
the one being doormatted here
then you start connecting what looks
like seemingly random pieces of
information
right shoes by the door 30 minutes late
here
um remember that time he hooked up with
that woman before we were even dating
remember uh remember i mean it all
bundles together
and when you go looking for something
especially when you're looking for a
resentment
you'll find it all day every day he
didn't put the cup
exactly the way it goes he didn't do the
dishwasher on purpose he did
all these things take this personal bent
to him right
and then all of a sudden you're setting
yourself on fire
just so other people can see the smoke
right
yeah and living with somebody who's not
honest with you
living with somebody who's not in love
or not honoring of themselves and so
they're always chasing
and they're always he's a schemer is
that who he is
he's always got a thing yes
what's he do for a living he's in law
enforcement
yeah okay oh he's got a plan a new thing
hey i talked to this guy hey i met these
guys and we're gonna is that guy is that
what he does
yeah okay and he's got a incredibly
demanding job that never stops right
it's 24 7 365 and he comes home
experiencing or living with other
people's trauma
all day every day so he doesn't have to
plug back in and also and you're lonely
and it just cycles that way right
so yeah there's an old ester perrell
quote
that i just love and i'm gonna butcher
it a little bit but
the gist of it is adults have
two to three three to four deeply
committed
monogamous relationships in their adult
life
and if they work really hard they're
with the same person
and where you are right now
is right on the precipice you're
starting to choose resentment
and i use that word intentionally it's a
choice to see
all the things that are happening as
personal attacks on you
not that your husband is flailing and
that he's really struggling and that he
may be feeling a lot of shame because he
took a job away from
fill in the blank or he doesn't know how
to deal with the trauma of his job or or
it's all has looped back to become about
you and that happens when we're lonely
it happens when we're disconnected it
happens when we're frustrated happens
when we're exhausted when we're being
traumatized etc
but when you start choosing resentment
then you are choosing to
make a left turn out of this
relationship so you started the call by
telling me your husband's wonderful
i haven't heard any of the wonderful
part tell me what's wonderful about him
i think just his character he is so far
so far you've told me he's so far you've
told me he's a guy that doesn't come
through
so i see that in certain aspects of him
but he's just a guy with deep deep honor
i think that is why he is in the job
that he is
and he was in the military before he
he does love the serving aspect and he
does
love the brotherhood aspect and the
honor and
he has honored me in a lot of
other ways through you know some
personal brokenness as well
which is why i want to i don't want our
marriage to
end i don't want i want to love him
through this
and i don't want to because i
i do see him struggling yeah does he
know does he know he's struggling
i think he's starting to come around to
it okay um
i think he sees you know there's some
anxiety that has popped up in the last
year or so and so he's starting to see
that things are catching up to him and
but i don't know that he knows how to
work past them
and i don't want to not support him
through it
um but i like you said i
i understand what you say about choosing
resentment and i don't want to
go that route like i said he has love
he has loved me through my own struggles
early on in our marriage
um and i want to do that for him does it
make sense
what i'm saying that you start to
looking for it and then ultimately you
start seeing it
absolutely there are things that you
start taking things personally
yeah exactly yeah it has nothing like he
leaves his pants over the back of the
chair
like that nothing to do with you but it
feels like man he's just sitting in the
middle of the living room flipping you
off and his mighty tidies right that's
what it feels like right
and so here here's what i would love for
you to do so i'm gonna do two things i'm
gonna send you
three i'm gonna send you three copies of
my redefining anxiety book for free okay
and i want you to read one
i want you to give him one it's like 60
pages or
80 pages it's really simple and it's
short okay
and it has weirdly resonated with not
weirdly it's a
group i grew up with through law
enforcement communities
and it's simple and it's direct but
here's what it will be for you
it'll be an avenue for you to talk to
him
and it'll be an avenue for you to say
i'm in on this too
this isn't me poking at you saying you
fix all this and then i will
this is saying hey i am arm in arm we
are joined at the hip on this one
because we're
we're in this thing together and then i
want you to provide him an avenue where
he can
open up with you what's he struggling
with
has he ever done that with you
um in some ways
about things here or there with his
i know there was a lot of trauma with
his military experience and same with
law enforcement
and if i ask he shuts down okay so it's
really when he offers
up stories here and there and i don't
always know what to do with them
that's right other than just listen it's
easy to
personalize that and say that he's
leaving you out of the loop what i will
tell you is
i know a lot of military guys have
worked in military guys worked with
police officers and a lot of time that
is a their way of loving you the best
they know how which is to protect you
from some of the most awful things a
human can ever see
right and so what it does is it does
create a wedge and it does create
secrets and it does create a gap in the
relationship but it's not
done maliciously right
it's done caring so you have to work
with those couples on bringing them back
together
talking in ways that each other can
understand but also not trying to
just bring a dumpster fire to the living
room right so
right um i'm gonna send you that book
and i want you guys to read that thing
together i'ma send you a third one that
you can just give out to a friend of his
or to
somebody in your short circle that y'all
can all start to have a common language
okay
here's what ultimately you need i want
you to think of the first 11 years y'all
have
been ride or die together you've been
with him through some hard stuff through
military service he's walked obviously
walked alongside you doing some hard
things
now he transitioned into a new place
yeah i don't have a lot of community
he's in a stressful stressful job
he's serving serving serving serving and
so i want you to look at
the first decade that you all have been
right or die through
there's a period at the end of that one
and now what you all get to do
and i say get to on purpose you'll get
get to
excavate that thing and recreate
something totally new
and amazing and awesome that is still
you too
but it's going to be a different picture
and it's going to look differently
you are going to respond to each other
differently and you're going to ask for
help differently
and you're both going to commit to going
to see a marriage counselor together
which you
both desperately need to do together
he's going to work on dealing with the
stuff he
saw overseas you're going to begin a new
phase and that way you're not
dragging this old relationship forward
and trying to cram
counseling or new ways of talking into
an old way nope it's a control alt
delete
and you're going to listen and you're
going to see those things you're going
to choose this and it's so hard it's
something you've got to practice
you're going to choose to see the pants
hanging over the back of the couch
curiously
not judgmentally does that make sense
you're going to ask him hey why do you
have your pants on the couch would you
want me to just move the closet out here
is that super easy
you can choose that or you can choose
that son of a he is
right you can choose one of the one or
the other or when he doesn't take his
plate over
um or he's 45 minutes late getting home
and he smells like arby's and you just
know he stopped on the way home right
you know this you can choose hey do you
hate my cooking
is arby's really better than how i cook
or
you can choose to go to war with him
you're gonna die and you're gonna right
all that
and i want you to begin to approach him
curiously not judgmentally and this is
going to be in decade two
the new decade for andy and her hot cop
husband
right and you're gonna listen
to hear and not just formulate a
response you're gonna listen to go to
listen
you're gonna listen to to heal and not
just find injustice right
this is where you're both going to agree
hey this was the first decade and we
practiced and tried and collapsed and
did good and had fun
and here's we're going to level up to
2.0 we're going to be highly intentional
about it
sounds like he's a man of high high
character like you say he is
and he'd be all in if you sat down and
said here's what i want to do
and you can start with this little book
of mine you can start with a
local community i don't care what you
what what group you do
but you have to excavate what was and
choose
together to build something new
something where you're both alive and
that may mean he quits his job and
you'll move
that may mean you go visit family that
may mean you go get a job who knows what
that means do you have kids too
we have two little girls how old are
they
my oldest is 10 and my other one's
turning far on friday
oh dude you got the gap like i do are
they awesome they're
so amazing okay can i do something andy
that's not fair but it's honest
yes you promise it's okay what i'm about
to do because it's gonna be not very
cool
yeah please don't teach them to resent
their husbands
i'm trying i know you are i know you are
please don't teach them resentment teach
them
that their vision is worthy
that their needs are worthy that yelling
and screaming and complaining solve
nothing and that it's okay to
cry it's okay to be hurt it's okay to
ask for more it's okay to laugh
and to be curious it's okay to say whoa
that was a fun decade it was hard and
it's time to do something new
teach them all those things
because you deserve that they deserve
that did somebody teach you resentment
andy
yeah yeah so that forest fire stops with
you
the one that is burned down through your
family tree it stops with
you can i tell you this andy i'm
so proud of you what a stud
thank you stops with you let's excavate
and start this whole thing over
i'd love love love to talk to your
husband if he ever wants to call a show
i'd love to talk to him he sounds like
an awesome guy
and i love talking to police officers
stay on the line kelly's going to get
you a couple of copies of this book
and we're going to get your family on
the road to healing all resentment is
again for everybody
it's when we believe and it could be
true
we believe that we are not getting the
recognition we deserve we don't we're
not getting the celebration we deserve
that the world is throwing a party and
they left us out
and resentment is choosing to focus on
that
on all of the things around me that
aren't right that aren't fair that are
being done
against me in my home in my with my
parents with my whatever relationships
at work
it's really hard to come back from
resentment and resentment travels from
kid to kid
it just weaves its way through family
systems and work systems
just all over the place don't choose
resentment i'd rather see somebody
choose to walk away
i'd rather choose somebody somebody
choose to go be alive go do something
wild and fun and crazy
don't choose resentment because it's a
forest fire that burns through family
systems
thank you so so much for your call andy
we're gonna take a break we'll be right
back
hey i wanna take a quick break and talk
about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with
better help for customized online
therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com for 10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today
hey all right we're back let's go to
david in austin texas hey david what's
going on
hey dr galoni good afternoon i hope
you're well i'm good man how about you
oh well i was doing great i wouldn't be
calling you i think
i'm laughing with you not at you man um
right
cool so what's up brother how can i help
all right here's my issue
uh my wife and i just had our first baby
uh
actually a month ago yesterday and uh
i hey talk directly into the phone david
all right can you be better perfect so
you just you and your wife just had your
first baby
a month ago how old are you i'm 40.
40. all right you're in it now brother
all right so you just had your first
baby and now what
uh well i'm finding out i don't really
like them
um it's not that i dislike him but he's
he's like a little
appliance that needs food and diaper
changing and this paternal feeling that
i'm supposed to feel
it hasn't arrived yet and i know
something's wrong and i don't know how
to
how to approach fixing it can i just
tell you something man
i yes you're a brave dude
and i have heard what you just said
so many times and it's a giant
secret that drowns new parents
and so i want to high-five you and
applaud you and tell you i'm grateful
for you reaching out
and for having the courage to say that
out loud have you told anybody else that
or am i the first person you're telling
uh
no you you and your show okay well
dude i um i'm grateful that you trusted
me that with
with that that's a heavy thing i know
you've been carrying around
so you have a new baby you're waiting
for all this run-up
nine months and then you have this baby
did the birth go well everything went
fine normal
everything went really textbook at the
very end we wound up doing a cesarean um
which wasn't planned but
every everything's healthy okay
everything's how it should be
okay and then you get home and it's a
month later
and you were waiting for this big
like angels to start singing and the
music to swell
and all you have is this little wrinkled
up lump of a human that stole your wife
from you and now it's taking all your
money and just
craps all day and doesn't sleep and it's
pretty much ruining everything
is that about right yeah
yeah i've got two of them man
so what were you expecting to feel man
well
kind of what i'd heard my entire life is
the first time you hold
your baby it doesn't matter how it comes
out how healthy it is how
whatever you're just gonna melt you're
gonna feel emotions you've never felt
before
uh you're gonna step lighter
walk stronger and be a better man from
then on and
it's it's like i'm babysitting yeah
hey whoever told you that wasn't telling
you the truth okay
maybe some dudes have that i didn't have
that
the first time i held my son i think my
words were oh crap
this is for real
right yeah and i'll tell you right now
my son's 11 years old
and i love him deeper than i knew i had
capacity for i didn't
i found chambers of my heart that i
didn't know existed
but it wasn't on day one
it wasn't on day five it wasn't on day
30. we had to grow into it
it was a chore i had things i had to do
here's what was really hard
i was an older parent like you are okay
i wasn't 40 but i was in my 30s
so i had a structure i had things that i
knew i liked i had things
i know the way i work and how i can be
successful and suddenly all that got
dumped over
right and so i'm
you're having to learn everything on the
fly and you're 40 bro
give yourself some grace okay
what i want you to do is to not let this
lack of emotion this lack of feeling
turn into a lack of doing the right
things
you know yeah i can understand that i
think i do yeah
you know i care for him i change him i
hold him
okay yeah and i want you to talk to him
i want you to continue to show up and
love
love love his mama
serve her take care of her as she heals
from a major surgery we just kind of
blow through yeah i had a c-section
that's a major surgery man
yeah it is honor her love her you're
gonna have a season with no sleep or
very little sleep you're gonna have a
season where your work schedule's all
screwed up and your marriage is
all weird and you don't know what you
just look and all of that gets zeroed in
on this little
bitty guy over here in the corner
and man it's hard
i'm sure there are guys who held their
baby and the chorus
like oh it all came it didn't happen for
me
my daughter was different and it's not
just because she was my daughter but she
was i knew what to expect at this point
so i knew that um these little
miracles are pretty resilient
you're not gonna break them and
my son by that time had taught me so
much about myself it was a gift
and so there is a
i don't call it a depression because
that sounds um
sounds prescriptive and i don't do that
there's gonna be a dip you're gonna have
a low where you just get exhausted
you're gonna have to know when you've
got to reach out for help you're gonna
have to have a buddy or two that you can
text and reach out to and
say hey is this normal and they'll go
yeah sucks huh
or yeah dude just change the diaper get
over yourself
and you need to have those guys in your
life and if you don't have them get them
today
okay that may even be your old man and
uh but you got to have some guys in your
life that you've got at the text
at on your text on a text thread that
you can just communicate at a moment's
notice
and then you got to know when hey honey
i need to go for a walk right now
you got to know when i'm not doing okay
i need to call a counselor because i'm
i'm thinking of bolting on this deal i'm
thinking of walking out the door because
i'm
going to tell you this dave you're not
going to walk out the door is that right
that's correct you're in is that right
yes good so now now it's a matter of
choosing to do the right things
i think in my heart you love this kid
it feels different than you thought it
was gonna feel or that they told you it
was gonna feel whoever they is
right and here's what's awesome if you
have another one
in four years i know you're going
no way man yep i'm putting it on you
dude you have another one in four years
you're gonna tell everybody when i held
my first son my light everything just
changed man you're just in the fog of
the first 30 days okay
so i want to tell you i don't think
you're crazy do you think you're crazy
i don't think i'm crazy okay you just
think you got lied to
well i mean now after speaking with you
i think that's probably the case
uh before when i was waiting i was
thinking you know what's wrong with me
listen if every guy was like all right
listen here's what's happening
you're gonna lose your wife for about
two years and
um this kid's gonna take 90 of your
income
and it's going to crap everywhere oh and
they tell you how to change
a diaper no it's 10 a day a day
forever and then your buddies are
finally gonna be like hey
we've been we've been waiting for a
couple of years we're ready to start the
business you all in and you're like
nope gotta hang out with the kid because
wife's gonna go what
if if everyone told everyone that no one
would have kids right
and here's the other thing in short
order you're gonna have a buddy reach
out to you
because this happened to me this
happened my buddy john king one of my
best friends on planet earth
he has a baby and
maybe six months eight months in we all
got together every week every monday
night we got together
as a group of us then slowly he quit
coming
dude what is he doing and his wife jen
is incredible she's one of my best she's
one of the best best friends in the
world
hilarious awesome but dude i was like
man
this guy's wife is killing him he can't
even go out with us one night a week
what is the deal here and he was always
so honoring
of his wife of his new baby and it was
about six months after i had hank
that that group of guys called me and
like hey guys we're gonna go out
and i started saying no man
i'd never occurred to me that he'd
rather sit at home and hold this little
lump of a six month old and go hang out
with our idiots
right more on faces at some bar
somewhere
all that to tell you is this
don't beat yourself up over how you're
feeling do the right thing
make sure you're loving that kid you're
touching that kid you are
hugging that kid you're holding that kid
you're taking him outside you're taking
him out walks changing his diapers
you're doing all those things that you
need to do make sure you have a
community of guys around you
right that you are eating right that
you're moving you're exercising that
you're sleeping when you can
keep doing the things that you know
you've got to do to keep you healthy
and i promise you
you will feel new parts of your heart
begin to open up
and it's slow and it's a pro it's a it's
a
it's a journey
and then you'll go whoa it'll be the
first time you go for a walk
and a dog comes running at you in the
stroller
and you find yourself saying oh that
dog's gonna die right then you think
well where'd that come from i like dogs
and i like dogs too but not more than my
kid right you'll find these moments
somebody will mouth off to you your kid
in a restaurant
and then your eyes will turn black and
you'll realize
or you'll hear that cry and you'll pop
up in the middle of the night and you'll
want to go
grab them out of the bassinet whatever
it is it looks different for everybody
don't beat yourself up you're a good dad
you're not going anywhere david you're
gonna stick around you're a good dad
you're all in feelings or feelings and
emotions or emotions don't beat yourself
up man
keep keep doing the right things keep
doing the right things thank you so much
for that call david man you made my
heart feel good
and you made me ah you reminded me
man
we oh man i don't want to get on some
james i don't get on some tan right
some rant here
there is no right way to feel about some
of these things
oh when i got married i was gonna feel
this i thought as soon as he
asked me to marry him i'd feel like that
and i thought when i found out i would
be pregnant this i'd feel like this and
um i thought as soon as i held my baby
like david man i thought this would all
be
me and there is no external
plug to an internal hole there is
nothing out there quote unquote that
will fix you
in here
and we have all these instagrammed and
and pinterestized
and great grandma eyes
directions on how we're supposed to feel
on some of these major life milestones
and if you don't feel that way
or you don't think that you feel that
way you think you're broken
you think there's something wrong with
you or something wrong with your
relationship or something wrong with
your kid
often you're not you just feel different
and that's when you've got to write down
these feelings do you really not love
your kid no of course you do
do you really not love this guy who just
asked you to marry him of course you do
i don't know maybe you don't maybe you
don't but
generally speaking yes so what's true
about this it feels different
i gotta go plan a wedding that's gonna
be hard yep doesn't mean you don't love
it means it doesn't feel the same way
you thought it was going to
that's okay that's okay
feel these feelings write them down and
then demand evidence from them
and like brave david did call somebody
call somebody if you don't know have
some people in your life you can reach
out to and be honest with man
david i'm proud of you brother you're
awesome you're awesome
um i'm gonna leave it at that man i'm
gonna leave it at that
we had a third call we'll take that next
call in the next show um
we have a some crew out here in the
audience thank you all so much for
coming
hey as we wrap up today's show on um
we've got the song
of the day yes sir before you do that
kelly and i
have a little something for you we are
approaching
show 150 coming up in a couple weeks
okay so we went ahead and got you a
little gift i'm gonna bring it in for
you okay
really
yeah seriously i didn't know you gave
gifts kelly
more than just my presence what is that
if you can't see podcasters james just
walked in with a
gibson guitar bag
james just brought me a gibson guitar
bag
what is this open it and find out
i see what you did there
listen call the bait and switch it's a
fender this is ridiculous
and it's mine you can't have it fine
forget you i am gonna play this i'm
playing the song of the day
i'm gonna
it sounds terrible why because it's not
a gibson ladies and gentlemen
or it's not in tune but as we uh wrap up
today's
show i'm gonna play us out on james
fender jaguar with all the switches hold
on
i'm going to turn the switches just just
right in the knobs
and um every rose has its thorn
oh god and the love of poison and all
things holy please stop just like
if renate
has its don't no no no
oh this is the dr john dolone show peace
out everybody
you're welcome everybody